aux etats unis la prison de guantanamo à
20 ans aujourd'hui l'occasion pour des
experts de l'onu de renouveler les
appels à la fermeture mais effectivement
il dénonce des années de détention
arbitraire sans procès accompagnés de
tortures les méthodes qualifiées d'
inacceptable pour un pays qui revendique
la protection des droits humains les
détails de notre correspondant aux états
unis thomas bonnin c'est une prison
source de multiples controverses et de
polémiques il y a vingt ans jour pour
jour guantanamo ouvrait ses portes sur
l'île de cuba une prison destiné à
recevoir notamment les accusés de
terrorisme
en 2003 la prison a accueilli jusqu'à
680 prisonniers plusieurs centaines
d'entre eux ont depuis quitté les lieux
ils sont actuellement encore 39 à être
détenu à guantanamo certains attendent
d'être transférés et d'autres attendent
tout simplement leur jugement c'est le
cas par exemple de celui qui se présente
comme le cerveau des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 son procès vient à peine
de démarrer à la fin de l'année dernière
alors lors de son arrivée à la maison
blanche joe biden avait promis de fermer
guantanamo mais près d'un an après son
investiture force est de constater que
la prison est toujours ouverte et il ya
toujours des inquiétudes sur les mauvais
traitements infligés aux prisonniers
écouté par exemple ce qu'en dit amnesty
international c'est une date
anniversaire qui n'aurait jamais dû être
atteinte depuis le gouvernement de
george bush il existe un consensus parmi
les experts en sécurité nationale et
l'ensemble de la classe politique au
sujet de la nécessité de fermer la
prison de guantanamo site tristement
connue pour la torture et la détention
injustifiable pour une durée illimitée
le président joe biden doit tenir son
engagement et fermer guantanamo
définitivement plus la prison reste en
fonctionnement plus elles minent la
crédibilité des etats-unis dans le monde
sur le terrain des droits humains il
faut se souvenir que barack obama avait
déjà a promis de fermer
guantanamo mais il s'était heurté aux
réticences du congrès américain alors
aujourd'hui des sources à l'intérieur de
la maison blanche explique aux médias
américains que joe biden a opté pour une
stratégie plus confidentielle en
permettant de manière ponctuelle le
transfert de certains détenus mais avec
un rythme si lent on peut imaginer que
d'ici la fin du mandat de joe biden la
prison de guantanamo soient toujours
occupée